and Andrew great to meet you in person
too so I'm here with the legendary the
legendary Dr Andrew lampkinen from
deepmind Andrew how are you finding the
conference having a great time so far
it's been amazing to see everybody in
person again and lots of exciting stuff
going on awesome so um you know what is
top of mind for you and what have you
been looking at recently
um I've been really excited about
language in many different contexts so
language and reinforcement learning and
language models their capabilities and
reasoning and so on and so I've been
excited to see tons of stuff that's
happening here in all of those domains
honestly
fantastic so um give me some examples
what you've been looking at yeah well
there's this this great um one of the
outstanding papers was srijan kumara's
work on using language or programs
specified in sort of like language-like
inputs to shape the inductive biases
reinforcement learning agents I thought
that was really cool work that's kind of
related to some of the things I've been
been interested in lately
um I thought that actually I found um
juho Kim's keynote really inspiring in
speaking about sort of like think about
the full interaction system like how AI
would interact with humans in a product
but I think that the the broader idea
that I really like there is thinking
about you know the full II interaction
system period so like when we're
thinking about the failures of let's say
a language model system in a certain
kind of reasoning we often don't think
about the full scope of how that system
would be deployed or how it would be
used in practice and I think that in
some sense this is actually a reason
that comparisons between the
capabilities of humans and the
capability of language models are a bit
scared because humans are a full system
that's doing many kinds of things
language models are a very particular
component and the way that you would use
it in practice you might get more robust
performance by incorporating it into a
larger system
so on on the language models you know um
there's been a lot of discussion around
this reinforcement learning human
feedback which I think is quite
interesting I I think it kind of
brutalizes the model you know from a
robustness point of view but it makes it
more likely for us to anthropomorphize
it and think it's doing magical things
so you know um talk to me about the
possibilities of large language models
yeah I'm very interested in
some more analysis of the full extent of
what things like RL from Human feedback
do to these models because I don't I
don't think we really understand
everything there I mean one paper I've
been really interested in recently is
Laura really sought a paper I don't
think it's here I think it was just put
on archive on uh it was called something
like
large language models are not zero shot
communicators and she was looking at
these sort of kind of pragmatic
inferences that humans make that we're
very good at in showing that language
models don't do them so well zero shot
few shot prompting helps a bit but
actually the instruction tuned or maybe
the RL from Human feedback models are a
lot better and one story you could tell
is that there's something about that
interactive context sort of like getting
those interactions with humans that is
teaching you a bit of something about
pragmatics itself and so I thought that
work was really stimulating and
interesting from that perspective and
I'm excited to see more investigation so
fantastic and um but what are your
thoughts at the moment about the the
grounding problem with the with respect
to large language models well yeah
that's a great question it's something I
want to think a lot more about I mean
I'm
I tend to think that it's possible in
principle to learn through language
alone anything that can be tested
through language alone but that's a very
different question from saying that you
know you can then just easily apply a
language model to some sort of grounded
context and I think that some of the
successes and failures people have seen
of applying language models to things
like you know language models is part of
a a image discussion system like in our
Flamingo model or as part of an RL
system you know you do see some
breakdowns I think it's because we
haven't figured out the right way kind
of as I was mentioning with Kim's talk
we haven't figured the right way to put
these models into a full system in a way
that makes them robust I think part of
it is that we haven't figured the right
way to really tie them down into the
ground again it's interesting is there's
definitely interesting work to be done
I've been speaking to a lot of people
that have been talking about
um you know reality plus augmenting
humans with language models but what
happens in tandem with with AI and
humans do you think that might you know
I'm skeptical I think language models
don't have agency intentionality
creativity lots of magical things that
we have
um what do you think might happen when
when we enmesh the two together yeah I
absolutely think that's a valuable
Direction I mean you know there's lots
of systems that don't have agency or the
things we have like even you know a
programming language like python or
Mathematica or something they're the
nevertheless very powerful tools when
you put them in the hands of humans who
do have intentions in agency and so on
we can use them to do things that we
can't do on our own and so I think that
to some extent language models can serve
that purpose um I'm not sure that's the
limit of what they can do but it's
certainly one thing they can do but
again you have to think about how the
full system plays together and the
weaknesses that these models do have you
know they're not always factually
grounded so you may want to do something
like
you know tune the model in various ways
get it to refer to sources so that the
humans can actually check on what it's
reporting to them and so on but they are
powerful compendiums of knowledge at
least in principle and they can perhaps
enable us to do things more effectively
and more efficiently than we could
before amazing I'm interested to know
where you think agency starts because um
if you're cynical like me and you say
well the computers only do what we tell
them to do then you kind of I mean you
know sir actually traces back the
argument to you need biology to have
agency and and so on so but but another
less cynical argument if you're you know
like a computationalist and you think
it's all information would be something
along the lines of well the language
model it's a little bit like the bit of
sand in a pearl right and and it kind of
like you get the Pearl from the bit of
sound so those are the starting
conditions but where do you think agency
comes from
I'm not sure if I know the answer to
this I think it goes back to some of the
deep philosophical issues around things
like free will right is there is there
really much that much difference between
a language model that perhaps is doing
everything we talked to or computational
system that's doing everything we talk
to and us if we are actually just sort
of like deterministically following the
evolution of the wave function of the
universe or whatever however you want to
think about it and there's a fairly big
debate about the extent to which we do
have free will and I I'd be interested
to ask you how that impacts your
thinking about the agency that we do or
don't have maybe you think you know
biology and quantum mechanics somehow
come together to resolve it
um I honestly don't know and there are
so many different ways of of looking at
it yeah so you can you can use the the
Penrose argument as you just said or or
sales argument or you can just think
that it that it just naturally emerges
from from information but
um okay this is really interesting so um
what else is top of mind for you at the
moment
um I yeah so I'm very interested in
these grounding problems actually quite
generally because I'm I'm interested in
applying you know language to
reinforcement learning and I've done a
lot of work in sort of language models
and a lot of work in language plus
reinforcement learning but not that much
work tying them together I'm interested
in that and that requires really
tackling this grounding problem
seriously
um but I'm
just before just to hold that thought
could you sketch out an example so I'm
applying language to a reinforcement
learning agent what would a good example
of that being yeah so there's been a a
few papers that have done things along
these lines there's kind of a wide scope
of things you could do I mean there's
things like um Helm that basically use a
language pre-trained language model is
just some sort of inductive bias for
initializing your your um your RL agent
and it's you're not really using that
language in a particular way there's
systems more like react let's say that
do some sort of more language like
planning and try to use that to control
an agent or second does something like
with sort of an earlier version of that
um and I think that there's you know a
wider range of things that could be
explored some of my colleagues they
should Ada Gupta and Co are presenting a
paper at a workshop today on using sort
of language systems there some at say
cam like way but where the system
actually sort of gets the agent to get
gather information from the environment
and provide that report that back to the
language model to help it to reason
through the correct solution to the
problem and so I think there's kind of a
wide range of things that you could
possibly explore in the space and part
of the question is well which which of
these are actually effective and you
know do you need to fine-tune the
language model in order to do that or do
you want to freeze it so you preserve
its knowledge or do you want to you know
train some sort of do like parameter
efficient fine-tuning there's like
there's a huge space of things you could
consider there awesome so um this this
grounding thing it comes back to the
very simple notion of syntax versus
semantics and Cyril of course spoke
about that
um what's the general I mean are you a
rare breed or are loads of people in the
community thinking about this as a
serious problem
I think that
I think that there's perhaps a little
less worry about that in the community I
mean I think there's you know lots of
people are thinking about it hard but I
think language models have shifted The
Narrative on this a little bit because
first of all we see that they're capable
of learning quite sophisticated
syntactic structures from language alone
and of course they do that from a lot
more data than humans get so it doesn't
it's not like that alone refutes
chomsky's arguments about poverty the
stimulus or anything but it is
suggesting that well maybe the kind of
separation of syntax and semantics that
you have in Chomsky style Linguistics at
least is not a necessary feature of the
system at the scales that we're training
them now and of course I mean if you're
depending on your perspective you might
think that these models have absolutely
no semantics because they are just
observing words and maybe semantics is
something Beyond language entirely so
yeah depending on your perspective you
might see these models is actually a
separation of syntax and semantics it's
very interesting now um you wrote that
beautiful paper and you were King you
know Pierce's Triad and and also
speaking about Wittgenstein and so on
and you know again this is what
so-called
um the matter of um epistemic um
subjectivity and observer relative
Concepts and and so on so um that to me
that that kind of um relativistic
worldview is is almost anathema to the
to the modus operandi in the community
so um how much traction are you getting
with that view
I don't know I guess we'll have to see
in five or ten years where the community
is I mean I think these things always
sort of evolve over time my sense is
that people are much more open to the
possibility that language models say
have some kinds of knowledge that would
be useful for solving problems in
practice and I'm not sure they're I
guess this is kind of what I mean I'm
not sure they're so concerned about the
philosophical discussions about like
well do they have any meaning or don't
they for instance or is it all relative
meaning can they can they know the true
meaning of anything if the system is
effective in practice and so my
intuition although I'm certainly not
sure of this is that we will see an
increasing shift towards just deploying
language models as part of a larger
system to do some some task and it will
be improved both by scaling of language
models possibly things like you know
multimodal training with them that may a
improve some of these grounding issues
possibly things like interactive
training RL from Human feedback or more
sophisticated methods that may improve
some of these issues but I think people
will perhaps stop worrying about this to
the extent that they see the systems
just being increasingly effective in the
world that would be my prediction
so I've been so impressive language
models when they first came out I agreed
with Bender that they were
stochastically parrots so I agreed with
Marcus that they were below theaters and
now I'm I'm hopped I'm halfway on the
Continuum right they're doing really
really amazing things and you just tell
them what to do in natural language they
do what you want to do and then we get
to this notion of well well are they
behaving intelligently and we can use
the lens of behavior and you know you
get this receding Horizon of mimicry and
when the mimicry reaches a threshold we
kind of think okay this thing is the
real deal and Melanie Mitchell said oh
maybe it's another mode of understanding
what do you think
yeah I mean I
in some sense yes so I I agree with that
sentiment at least that it's you know
as things recede into oh well language
models actually could do that we do
start to you know rethink things a bit
and eventually at some point it just
feels like well maybe maybe this is just
another mode of understanding I do I
also agree that it's a different mode of
understanding like I certainly don't
think we understand the world through
language Alone
um that would be kind of a radical
footer style language or thought way to
think about things but I I think that
our understanding is much more embodied
and grounded and so that I I think that
our understanding of all the concepts we
talk about in languages probably vastly
different than the understanding that
these systems have but I guess the the
question is the extent to which it's
different in a meaningful way that
impacts the capacities of the system
like is the difference in my
understanding of some concept uh
something that you can assess by talking
to me in language alone and is it
meaningfully different from the language
models in a way that impacts my ability
to reason about that concept better than
that model or not
um
and I think that's that's the key
question and I don't think we fully know
the answer now but like you I've been
impressed with how far these models
could get from text along fascinating
now um linguists Still Still cites
folder and pollution you know the um the
connectionism critique that I spoke
about productivity and systematistics
I'm not sure whether you studied that
but you've got a cognitive Science
Background so you're probably okay with
that and I just wondered how relevant I
mean you know I think Gary Marcus's
compositionality argument is kind of in
in that line of thought how relevant do
you think that argumentation is today
my perspective on this which we
mentioned a bit in our symbolic behavior
that you mentioned earlier is that
humans are certainly not perfectly
systematic compositional generalizers
and that can be seen in a wide variety
of cases in terms of the sort of
recursive grammar structures that I
looked at in a recent paper or in terms
of our logical reasoning or in terms of
even you know people who do sort of like
classic you know composition experiments
with simple toy grammars in the lab like
Brendan like people are pretty good at
generalizing these grammars in some
sense but you know they're getting
something like 80 compositional
generalization which if you showed that
to Gary Marcus and told them it was from
a neural network you would probably say
oh that's just obviously the system
doesn't have real compositionality so I
think there's I think there's an issue
here which is kind of subtle which is
that I I never heard about this in a
recent paper which is that
Chomsky introduced this idea of the
competence performance distinction which
is the idea that the competence the
system has that is the underlying true
capability is different from you know
the performance it might exhibit in
practice so I think to some extent
everybody intuitively agrees with this
like even if you know how to answer a
question like a math question let's say
you might in practice make some mistakes
you perform differently than your
competence would allow you to in
principle because you're distracted or
you're sleepy or you know you just do
some math wrong in your head or whatever
and so but I think that that distinction
leads to very unfossifiable claims and
in particular it leads people to make
claims from like people exhibiting 80 or
90 compositional generalization that oh
people really have a compositional
competence and the rest of this you know
the 10 20 errors is just noise it's just
you know mistakes of performance it's
not something deeply meaningful but
people analyzing neural networks take
that claim that humans have a
compositional competence at face value
and so if they see the network not
exhibiting perfect performance they say
oh it's doing something different than
humans and so they're not giving the
benefit of the doubt the competence
performance distinction to the model in
the same way that they are to humans and
I think that this makes the comparisons
between humans and models very
challenging
just not even to set aside all the the
stuff that I mentioned earlier the juho
Kim style stuff about you know the model
as part of a larger system and humans
being competent more exhibiting better
performance perhaps because of the other
systems we have intervening
that was a really good answer you
mentioned Chomsky we spoke to Chomsky
recently and as you know he's got a bit
of a bad take on deep learning um he
says it's not a contribution for science
he likes bulldozers too they're good for
clearing the snow but uh you know he
thinks that we've we've given up on
trying to understand many things in
science partially because it's beyond
our cognitive Horizon
um what would you say to Chomsky
I would say I mean I I think it's useful
for people to have different
perspectives and you know Chomsky has
certainly inspired a lot of the
linguistic field to think about things
the way he has and I think a lot of the
field as you mentioned earlier are
continuing to not see deep learning as
the fundamental answer to understanding
these things so I'm not I'm not too
concerned that we will give up on
seeking other kinds of understanding but
I'm also optimistic that the successes
of deep learning in learning things like
language can give us new hypotheses
about where the human language
capability might come from and indeed
people have been investigating things
like whether you can get a language
model to learn you know human language
like representations from a more
reasonable amount of data kind of more
like what humans get
and I think it can afford US new ways of
investigating what the structure of
language knowledge looks like by looking
at the representations and computations
of these models and potentially arrive
at a more deep understanding of what
language actually is in the human system
so I'm I definitely think it's good for
people to be working on different
perspectives on this but I'm really
excited about this era this new era of
language research and I hope that
eventually the rest of the linguistic
field will come around to that as well
amazing and in that vein what's the most
important research question that you're
going to try and answer this year
we're coming here
oh boy uh
I'm not sure yet I'm planning to take
some time after this conference to
brainstorm and think about what the most
important things to work on next are
this issue about grounding is very high
in my mind so that that may be one of
their fundamental questions I want to to
tackle and you know what what would be
learned differently from a model that
was learning in a more embodied setting
like humans are and what things might be
learned much more efficiently
if if it's even possible to learn from
language alone what might be learned
much more efficiently for an embodied
agent so those kind of questions are
very interesting to me oh and you just
triggered me with the e word which is
wonderful
um I'm just um I mean obviously I'm an
outsider to cognitive science but the
the fouries have been a really
interesting development over the last
couple of decades and my friend Mark
Bishop said it was um you know his only
place to hide If he if you don't like
computationalism but I just wondered is
is that your school of thought in the
40s
I
see myself as floating a bit between
different schools of thought I guess I I
definitely find certain things about the
embodied or even inactivist perspectives
interesting and I think they're very
useful ways to think about things I I
don't like being too committed to
computationalism or representationalism
in particular and I really like this old
paper from Paul sizak called uh beyond
the computer metaphor behavior is
interaction I find that quite inspiring
so I don't
I'm not committed to one of these
perspectives I think perhaps they're all
a little bit too extreme but I think
that it's useful to think about all the
different ways that we could imagine
that the brain is approaching the
problem of being a human doing things in
the world and perhaps by training agents
to solve these tasks and then seeing
what sorts of solutions they're arriving
at we can come to a hypothesis about
what it is that the brain is doing and
how it is solving that problem
amazing Dr Andrew Lantern thank you so
much for joining us today thank you so
much for talking to me